military records show the US soldiers
killed in each year three weeks ago had
little to no combat experience Pentagon
officials today plan to brief the House
and Senate Armed Services committees on
the attack that killed four Americans
lawmakers want to know how sergeant
David Johnson was separated from the
unit and if he was alive when wounded
soldiers were evacuated his body was
found two days later Margaret Brennan is
at the Pentagon Margaret good morning
good morning well for American and for
Nigerian soldiers were killed as their
Patrol sought information on a terrorist
considered a high-value target who had
recently been spotted in the area
the ambush has been described by
military officials as a complex attack
involving small arms fire and
rocket-propelled grenades military
service records released by the Pentagon
showed that sergeant lee david johnson
and the three other mortally wounded US
soldiers had little to no combat
experience for sergeant Dustin right
whose remains arrived at Dover Air Force
Base the day after the attack Nisha was
his very first overseas deployment a
Special Operations Command spokesperson
told CBS News the men had all completed
pre mission training required before
such deployments it's a dangerous
business President Trump on Wednesday
said his generals approved the mission
and he was just learning details I gave
them authority to do what's right so
that we win that's the authority they
have I want to win and we're going to
win and we're beating Isis very badly
the ambush was towards the end of a 24
hour mission the patrol had just met
with elders in tango tango and had
loaded up on fuel and water upon leaving
the attack began an hour into the
firefight the Patrol called for help and
French forces arrived 60 minutes later
once the military realized sergeant
Johnson was missing a dust want or duty
status whereabouts unknown was declared
triggering an intense search the
commander of US forces in Africa General
Thomas waldhauser
asked the chairman of the Joint Chiefs
Joseph Dunford for help and us commandos
based in the region were launched at
that point knowing that we had a missing
soldier we made a decision to make sure
that all of the resources to include
national assets were available
for the recovery that operation it is
still unclear whether this was a
pre-planned attack but investigators
believe it was carried out by an Isis
offshoot operating in the region
according to military officials that
group is led by this man adnan abu ali
al sahara he commands just 40 to 60
fighters but he's got allies throughout
the region
Gail all right Margaret thank you